darah is with us in New York City hi
Dara how are you hi Dave thanks so much
for taking my call
sure what's up my husband and I are in
baby set two and we have $33,000 to pay
off I'm thinking of ways for us to get
more ahead and gain momentum we have two
cars one we just got in April and
another we were gifted last October we
have $16,000 left on the car and we make
about $90,000 a year but in December my
husband is getting a $22,000 raise so
the entire time I was sitting there
filling out the paperwork to buy the car
I could just hear you telling you not to
do it so my question is why did you do a
car I'm sorry why did you do it well I
had a car that I mean are you hurt me
telling you not to do it why did you do
it well we didn't have any money to save
up and my car was beyond what it was
worth to have it fixed and I just I
didn't know what to do we didn't have
any money saved up to get a car so that
so you bought $16,000 car uh yeah yeah
sounds like an overkill for this
situation doesn't it yeah a little bit
so that's why I'm yeah the good news is
this if you don't leave if you learn to
listen to that voice in your head and
it's not Matt it wasn't my voice by the
way it was your own voice saying don't
do this stupid I've got that voice in my
head to tell me it's going to kill me
I'm not going to kill you it's your life
kiddo you're going to be okay the good
news is you guys are making good money
and if you'll bear down you can knock
out all of this debt and twelve months
right but you're going to bear down and
I would just now that you're there I
would keep it yeah it's not completely
out of line I just wish you hadn't done
it at the stage you did it in the way
you did it but if you had paid cash for
$16,000 for a year from now with your
income I wouldn't be upset about that at
all that would be fine and I wish you
always should just bought you a two or
three thousand dollar car to get by
until you got some of this other stuff
done that's what you should have done in
that situation but now we're here
and you know that's water under the
bridge milk is spilled no big deal let's
go on next thing we've all done stupid
stuff hey that makes you human it's all
good you're going to be fine but the
deal is this no eating out no vacations
get this deck cleaned up now fast lean
on it
learn from it get after it that's the
important thing and if you do that with
a 90 thousand dollar income plus $22,000
raise coming in December you'll be
debt-free in 12 months owing thirty
three thousand dollars including sixteen
thousand our stupid car which is half of
your debt so you're going to be fine but
you 12 months want this done
scorched earth on your budget don't do
anything no life until you get this
straightened up that's how you get out
of that you have to change the way your
brain works about money and when you
change the way your brain works about
money
permanently that's what I'm more
concerned about then the the the
particular mathematics in this situation
because that's how you live the rest of
your life in control and that's how you
change your family tree so you're doing
good you're going to make it you'll be
all right but that's what I would
suggest to you and I'd keep the car in
that situation if you're not willing to
go to no life and scorched earth you do
need to sell the car so that you can get
out of debt while you wander around
through restaurants and stuff and and
believe me I know there's some pretty
dadgum good restaurants in New York City
I love going up there that's one of my
route and food is one of my favorite
sports and so I'm I'm loving it you know
but I'm with you on that but you you're
not you you're not going to see one for
a year not while you get this mess
cleaned up so hey thanks for the call
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below